the jurgen experience i was a fan back
when you got [ __ ] over in the olympics
man
god damn did they ruin that that was
terrible that was one of the worst
olympic decisions i've ever seen in my
life maybe the worst
it was so bad but it was in korea right
yep it was in seoul south korea
in the korean fighter yeah but god damn
that was ridiculous it was one of those
fights where you're like well
he got the gold medal clear and then you
see the decision your jaw drops you're
like
what is this it hurt the sport of boxing
especially amateur boxing it hurt it
because
when you can take a kid 19 years old he
defeats his rival
clearly and you rob him it
really eliminates the integrity of that
sport
yeah and you still don't go back and fix
it nobody to this day has come back and
tried to fix it
they gave me olympic orders they gave me
the
valve walker cup which is for the best
boxer at the olympics where
that's contradiction that's
contradiction how is the best boxer here
not wearing a gold medal yeah it was it
was bad but it
also was in one way it made people
really root for you
it was a blessing in disguise and i
understood that
the second day i think i might have
cried the whole first day
but the second day well i didn't cry
after i went to the back and asked
ask the interpreter to ask him if he
really thought he beat me
because if he said yes then he didn't
know it but he was gonna get another one
[Laughter]
but he said no i know i didn't win but
it wasn't my fault it was the judges
i shook his hand and i left and i never
had never another
bad feeling towards him because he he
didn't do it you feel me you're right
you still understand what what but then
i also realized that
not only were the judges not necessarily
they are to be blamed
but what god did was take their negative
and turn into a positive for me and look
who i'm at now it was a big talk like i
remember when you began your career
there was a big talk of your career how
you got [ __ ] over in the olympics it
was not
a it wasn't a question not at all there
was no debate
there's not i never saw a single person
that made an argument that he won
it was all you and so that when you
began your career you had a lot of
people rooting for you yes and that was
a beautiful thing that that's the
blessing
above all for me because to me it was
god's way of making me
not put my life on idol but turned me up
on high
yeah i had no clue what he was doing but
that's why you're just trusting god
look where you at now yeah i remember
when you fought james tony and that was
a big fight because james tony was in
his prime and you were in your prime
and uh again you caught him with that
leaping left hook man that crazy left
hook and dropped him
when you when you beat james tony like
that i think a lot of people had to go
whoa like he can do this to an elite
top of the food chain world champion
that's what makes a real superior
athlete not that
you can do it to guys who are beneath
you when you can do it to guys who are
supposed to be
your equal or above you that's when
you're really doing it
episodes of the joe rogan experience are
now free on spotify
that's right they're free from september
1st to december 1st they're going to be
available everywhere but after december
1st they will only be
available on spotify but they will be
free that includes the video the video
will also be there
it'll also be free that's all we're
asking just go download spotify
much love